the Joe Rogan experience I don't say I
believe in gravity you would think I was
crazy if I say it would be a crazy thing
to say look you know I believe there's
gravity there is gravity it's testable
it works but what do you always hear
when people are like if you want to
succeed what do you do you believe in
yourself and it's like wait what do you
mean believe in yourself I am myself why
do I have to believe in it right so
that's it
it's a clunky way of saying self-doubt
is crippling well the self-doubt self
you know rejection I hate myself I love
myself all these things have within it
this concept of the self and a lot of
folks have not spent much time really
exploring like well what is that what is
the self like what is my particular self
and I think it kind of IDEs via when we
are sasquatch you know this self or that
many people's self is very similar to
Bigfoot yeah it's a thing that they
imagine that there's signs of but
they've never really quite seen the
Bigfoot you know but you know remember
the feather in the trail it's a gift it
means he likes you yeah they would think
sasquatches were taking and leaving
gifts taking their gifts and leaving
their own gift swapping gifts yeah yeah
and we believed it
they believed they believed it the same
way people believe in a religion you
know yeah I have a friend and she was a
Mormon I've told the story before so
forgive me if you've heard it she was a
Mormon but I think it's important and
she was a devout her whole life and then
the family just fell out of it and then
they started realizing like they started
going into the history of it and they
started thinking it was preposterous it
was right around when Book of Mormon was
coming out too you know that hilarious
musical ends here it's great it's really
good but she was really honest about she
was like the problem is like growing up
in that fundamentalist background it
makes me very susceptible to like
healers and like psychics and
clairvoyance and [ __ ] are spiritual
people she's like I get sucked in to
[ __ ] and she was like almost kind of
upset yeah me no not almost like she was
kind of upset but like perplexed like
how do you rewire yourself when you
been trained to believe that a
fourteen-year-old boy in 1820 found
golden tablets that contain the lost
work of Jesus and all the Native
Americans were the Lost Tribe of Israel
oh my god I mean this is that's the
story 14-year old boy he had a magic
Rock he could read it
it's crazy she started looking into it
and she she's out John yeah I'm gone and
not sad to you man because like if you
take you could take some like basic
tenets which are true and not based on
it kind of reminds me of like you know
you hear someone who's taking ayahuasca
and he comes to you and he's got a
profound message that came to him from
some mythological creature a dragon a
butterfly has told him some kind of
profound [ __ ] thing and you realize
the bubble machine of profundity you got
a bubble machine for thirteen thirteen
oh yeah whenever we're talking about the
yeah the so you know caught up in
popping them though when yeah I know
that's a problem of getting too high
you're like that John what do we do is
just pop bubbles it's like for them to
really like take in the basic wisdom
they got from the mythological creature
they needed a mythological creature the
mythological creature said something to
them along the lines of you need to love
yourself more you need to give more to
your community whatever the message is
but if you're a bird driver said that to
you it wouldn't get through because it
wasn't like phosphorescent you have
multiple heads so similarly with these
religions what happens is you do get
some real transcendent wisdom that's
sort of timeless mixed in with it and
then the people because they realize
like oh my god it was kind of a fairy
tale they also reject the good stuff
inside of it and not to me is the big
tragedy of any kind of fundamentalist
literalist interpretation that's being
forced on people is because within that
is inevitably something great where it
wouldn't be so viral like Christianity
wouldn't be here right now if there
wasn't a core thread in it that had a
beautiful message in it he makes people
nicer people I actually
a really big conversation this weekend
with a very good friend about it about
another very good friend who's very
religious and we were saying like I
think for some people it's an amazing
framework and a guide to live your life
I really do believe that I have several
friends they're very devout Christians
yeah it's beautiful and they they're the
nicest people I know and Mormons by the
way I have friends that are Mormons
still to this day I have several friends
that are Mormons and they're some of the
nicest P yeah and I don't care if they
believe something that I don't believe
in that's okay it's okay
it is okay but I mean the idea that
everyone is supposed to buy into stuff
without questioning it is the reason why
we are 51 year old 16 year olds dude I
agree and then there's the deeper
symbolic [ __ ] it seems to be encoded in
Christianity whether from people
projecting their own understanding on a
pretty wild cymbal set or maybe it was
intentional either way there's like a
cool like you know the if we talked
about this like if you take a cube and
unfold it it makes a crucifix and like
the cube represents pre-big bang
conditions and the crucifix represents
past present and future intersecting
with eternity and so if you have a
square oh I get it so the length the
height is twice as the width
yeah it's okay make it unfolds into a
crucifix for people that are annoyed
with that sound it sounds like a pencil
sharpening over and over and over again
we're sorry sorry about that y'all but
bubbles don't come free you need hire
somebody hire some dude just blow
bubbles what are you blue bubbles on the
JRE bro
some like [ __ ] manly wrestler dude
[Applause]
yeah different people come in and blow
bubbles
and occasionally HR man hey I'm gonna be
on the Jerry next week what are you
doing I'm blowing bubbles oh cool you're
the bubble blower for the week you could
start something that became like that's
just what people do it's like did you
get your bubble man yet right yeah
a classic bubbleman I know how to do it
the new guys they're too loud when they
blow